hey everyone welcome to this video on
networking interview questions and
answers by simplylearn
in this video we will take you through
the top 10 networking interview
questions and answers that can help you
crack your interview
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
let's start off with question 1 what is
the osi model
explain the different layers of the osi
model osi largely is a theoretical model
utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created
and how they are being processed by a
computer
this is normally used by the tcp the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
software suite so osi
is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model
that describes how applications are
going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand
they are as follows so in this diagram
there are these seven different layers
we start off from the bottom first is
the physical layer the data link layer
network layer transport layer session
layer presentation and application
when such a question is asked in an
interview
it is not only that we identified these
seven layers
explaining what the osi model is in the
first place we then try to identify
these seven layers
and we give a brief description about
each and every layer
if there are any additional questions
they will come after
this basic question so let's start off
with the physical layer
this is the lowest layer of the osi
model now this is where
any and every physicality of your
computer comes into the picture
so it could be a network interface card
it could be an rj45 or a
cat5 cable anything that allows data to
be transmitted physically from your
machine
to another machine next comes the data
link layer
so on the data link layer as far as
networking is concerned we just need to
understand that
data packet is encoded decoded into bits
at this layer
this is also the layer that deals with
mac addressing so the physical address
of every
network interface card which is the mac
address which is utilized to
route data packets over the network this
is where the mac address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
datagrams are transferred from one to
another
the function of this layer are routing
and logical addressing the moment we
talk about
routing and logical addressing ip
addresses come into the picture ip
version 4 ip version 6.
so network layer will deal with ip
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for end to
end
that automatically signifies that this
is where tcp and udp will be working
tcp stands for transmission control
protocol udp for user datagram protocol
tcp is a connection oriented protocol
whereas udp is a connectionless protocol
these two protocols are utilized to
establish connectivity between two
machines
tcp is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent
data has been received and so on so
forth whereas udp is a connection less
protocol where data is just dumped
without verifying whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not
so in a nutshell on the transport layer
tcp and udp
make their appearance and this is where
that functionality lies then comes the
section
there this controls signals between the
computer it establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about tcp and udp
udp being a connection less protocol
where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas tcp we studied is more of a
reliable protocol
thus there are different packets signals
that will be sent across to verify that
data has been transmitted it has been
received properly
and then the next uh segment of that
data is being sent
so those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of tcp
the acknowledgement packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session layer
of the osi model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format
so the formatting right mime or encoding
that is
being utilized the utf-8 character set
that we utilize
for uh presentation encryption
mechanisms all of these work on the
presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses a
particular protocol
so that the other uh machine on the
receiving end
the application on that machine would be
able to understand what the
communication was about
right so in a nutshell if if i start
from up top
the application layer will deal with any
of the data that the application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing the
username password
all that data will be constructed let's
say into an http or https format
that's where application layer comes
into picture then the formatting of
which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a tcp session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity ip
addressing would be done on the network
layer mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer
and when everything is ready on the
physical layer the packet will be sent
out
at the receiving end the packet will be
received on the physical layer and then
all these
layers will be reversed and finally at
the application layer the data would be
presented to the application
who would then execute it and showcase
it on the screen
of the recipient so this is the way you
want to explain this
question you want to be very concise
precise about what you're explaining you
don't want to go into two hypothetical
scenarios
you don't want to delete earlier with
the
layers you just want to give the basic
functionality want to demonstrate that
you understand what the osi layer is
how the computer functions and you want
to move on from there
if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again
most of your interview questions are
designed that way
it's basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
technologies so you have to be very
concise
don't go rattling about technology too
much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is
so when data is being transmitted over a
network it can be
transmitted either in one of these
particular manners it can either be a
unicast
multicast or a broadcast so what is
unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user
to a single receiver so one to one
right so uh one machine talking to
another machine and nobody else so are
also known as point to point
communications
one point two one of the point if you
have to send information to multiple
receivers
then you will have to send it using
multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into picture so in our
case
uh let's assume it's a network where
there are uh there's a class c
network approximately 255 odd machines
and within these there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to point
communication where they will utilize
unicast
where only these two machines will have
visibility of that conversation
and the other machines will not even
realize that this conversation is taking
place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines
then the multicast comes into the
picture as the name suggests in this
mode of communication data is sent from
one
or more or more sources to multiple
destinations
multicast uses the internet group
management protocol also known as the
igmp protocol
to identify groups so under this igmp
protocol
various groups are created where
machines
are subscribed to those particular
groups and whenever a message needs to
be sent through those groups
it will be identified by the igmp
protocol and then that particular
message will be sent
to those multiple machines that are
members of those particular groups
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast
as it says it is going to broadcast to
all so this is one to
all that is communication between a
single user and it is going to be sent
to all the machines in that particular
network right
so the three ways unicast is one two one
multicast is one to many and broadcast
is one to all then question number three
what is dns dns stands for domain name
system
it is like the internet's phone book
that is responsible for mapping the
domain name
into its corresponding ip address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a google chrome browser
we type in www.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
google comes in front of us the website
rather
now how does the computer know who
google is because as far as we are
concerned
humans understand google and words like
that computers don't computers
deal with binary zeros and ones right
and as far as internet is concerned they
will only deal with ip addresses and mac
addresses
so how does a computer know how to find
google.com and where is it located
so the moment we type in in the browser
window in the address bar google.com and
press enter
a dns query is generated automatically
by the browser
where a packet is sent to our dns
servers asking
what the ip address is so in short dns
resolves domain names to their
corresponding ip addresses
there is a dns server which will have
this index
a database of all the domains associated
with their ip addresses if one
particular dns server does not have that
information that you are looking for it
may query another dns server
who may have that particular response
so the first thing is when you type in
domain name
it gets resolved with the dns it
identifies the ip address corresponding
to that particular domain name
and thus allows the computer to route
that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local pc you have typed in
cybersecurity.com
there is a dns resolution that a query
that goes
to the dns server what is the ip of
cybersecurity.com
the dns server looks it up in its
particular uh database
if it has the corresponding ip address
it will then respond back the ip
addresses 172.17.252.1
after which the packet is sent off to
cybersecurity.com
moving on to question number four what
is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall
but that's the functionality of a
firewall that is what how we can install
a firewall
but there are different types of
firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall is either a hardware
or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming
or outgoing traffic from the internet to
your computer they secure a network so
essentially
the firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen
it won't go beyond that that's the basic
functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done
based on the rules that you have created
on the firewall it will then
based on those rules identify whether
some traffic is allowed
in that network or some traffic is to be
blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows the firewall
rules will analyze whether the traffic
is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic
and not allow that connection from
happening in the first place
now there are a few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question
and the first one is a packet filtering
firewall these are the most common types
that you will come across
which analyze packets and lets them pass
through only if they match an
established
security rule set now here people do get
confused when we say that we analyze
packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct when a definition
for a packet filtering firewall says
that these firewalls analyze packets
it means that they are only analyzing
the source and destination ip addresses
port numbers and the protocols that are
mentioned in those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection
or a dpi as it is known if that
capability comes into the picture you
are basically looking at an intrusion
detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next-gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets
for its source and destination ip
addresses port numbers and the protocol
that is being utilized it will then map
that information to the rules that are
there
on the firewall and based on those rules
it will either allow that a collection
to happen or disallow that connection
from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level
they work at the layer 7 of the osi
model
packet filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they've worked on ip
addressing and port numbers
will work on the network layer of the
osi model
also on the transport layer because you
also look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the
application layer of the osi model and
will deal with application level
protocols such as http
https ftp smtp and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer app inspection firewall
these filter packets of the network
transport and application
layers so they basically do the job
of the first and the second type of
firewalls
the packets are compared to known uh
trusted packets
but now the first question is if there
is a stateful multi-layer inspection
firewall
why do we have type 1 and type 2
firewalls like packet filtering and
proxy firewalls that is because that is
how the firewalls have evolved
we started off with the packet filtering
then we added functionality to it
and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall
is to allow good traffic and disallow
bad traffic based on the rules that have
been configured on the firewall
and then you've got basically three
types of firewalls packet filtering
proxy
and stateful multi-layer and just
include a brief description
of each of these firewalls if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection
between a vpn server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
tunnel
between the client and the vpn server
which is then utilized
to secure the connections that you
you're making with the
internet so as you can see in the
diagram the user has a vpn client
installed on the machine
the vpn client then creates an encrypted
tunnel to the vpn server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted
which can then be processed by the vpn
server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server
the vpn server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the
communication mechanism they will not be
able to do so because of the encrypted
it is very difficult to decrypt this or
hack through this encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing
now before we go into advantages of
distributed processing we first have to
understand what is distributed
processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an application
here multiple computers across different
locations
share the same processor the advantages
of distributing processes
are as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing
is basically where multiple machines
will pull their resources together
to run a singular application so an
application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required
the advantages are that it can be very
very useful in data recovery for example
raid
where you're striping data on various
hard disks
it is reliable it is cheaper lower cost
can be achieved
and it is easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just
talked about if there is loss of data in
one computer it can then be recovered
by another interconnected computer and
one of the examples would be
blockchain in today's world right what
is blockchain that this data is
uh created live and stored on a
connection of computers so if one of the
computers goes offline
the other computers in that network will
still have that data
and the blockchain will still function
without any issues
the second point a glitch in one machine
does not affect the processing as there
will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
mainframe machine so instead of having
a server bank i can have multiple
machines connect interconnected together
and they can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanism
depending on the amount of data
processing
more computers can be attached to the
network thus you can increase the number
of computers that can be
a part of that blockchain or you can
reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is tcpip
or transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
is a set of communication protocols that
are used to interconnect networking
devices
on the internet this protocol defines
how data should be transmitted over the
internet
by providing end-to-end communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be
established on your machine you will
need tcp
without tcp ip there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss
tcp is a software that once installed on
your machine
will then interact with the hardware
which is your network interface cards
and then your switches wires cables and
all those through protocols that have
been already pre-configured in it
so within the tcp iep suite of softwares
you will have all the protocols all the
functionality of the osi layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer will be
predefined
and pre-configured to work in a
particular manner the internet protocol
is all about routing each individual
packet to make sure it reaches its
destination
so with the tcp you're talking about the
protocols that will allow you to
format the data and generate it so that
you can communicate it over the network
the ip will then deal with the routing
of those packets so that
the packet can be routed to the correct
computer and be received by the
recipient
so the tcp model is the compressed
version of the osi mode the seven layers
will get converted into four layers the
network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question
eight
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands
the first one on a windows machine the
second one on a linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the internet
protocol configuration
this is a command that is used on the
command line interface of microsoft
windows
to view all the adapters and the
configuration of each and every adapters
for their network interfaces so as you
can see on the right hand side in the
command prompt screen
if once you type in the ip config
command on the c prompt
and press enter it will give you a list
of all the adapters that are there
so you can see wireless lan adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist
at the bottom you'll see the wi-fi
connection wireless lan adapter
and can give you the ip version 6 ip
address ipv version 4 address
the subnet mask and the default gateway
so this is the configuration that allows
the machine
to know on what network it is on what is
the default gateway for communicating to
the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may
exist in that particular network and
what is the ip address of that specific
computer
so that it can communicate across the
network as well
ifconfig is the same thing on the linux
mac or unix operating system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces
and the configuration of each and every
interface it is used to configure
control the tcp network interface
parameters from the command line
interface
it allows you to see the ip address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see
uh the wlp19s
the ipr is being 192.168.43.215
subnet mask being 255.255.255.0
with the broadcast being 192.168.43.255.
question nine what is the difference
between a domain and a work group
this can be a very interesting question
and can be a very lengthy question at
the same time
a work group is nothing but a
decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine
acts in its own individual capacity
thinks of itself as a server
right so a decentralized network you
every user manages the resources
individually on their pc
so local users on their own pcs
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth it is good if you've got a small
network
uh a few machines all together uh and
you want them to interact
with minimal management effort right so
each
computer each user will decide what they
want to allow
other users to see on that particular
network and all of them would be
connected over a lan a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home wi-fi right
now that is one of the best examples
of having a work group the domain on the
other hand is a centralized network
model
so in a corporate environment whenever
you go there and you got a domain based
username and password
which when entered onto a particular
machine gives you access
to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
it also uses a single sign-on
mechanism for all the resources that are
made that are to be made available to
you
whereas in a work group your local user
only meant
for that particular computer right so
coming back to the domain
it is an administrator who is going to
manage the entire domain and all of the
resources connected to the domain
the resources could be switches routers
servers data stores
applications web servers mail exchange
servers and so on so forth so all of
these
are administered by an administrator
through the domain
it is the most reliable and optimum
solution for a large network
where multiple users are going to
interconnect and share that data
amongst each other right the computer
can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a vpn you can connect to your corporate
network authenticate in
and get access to whatever resources you
are allowed to access whereas in a work
group
you have to be a part of that network to
access that particular network
if you change your location you go and
connect to another wi-fi you will lose
access to your previous wi-fi
then the last question for the
networking section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers
and trailers to the data the data link
layer
binds each packet into a frame that
contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation
we have talked about how data that has
been created by the application layer
we'd have a header and a trailer that
will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent
so the hardware address which is the mac
address comes into the picture and gets
added to the header
and the ip addresses port numbers and
all of those things
would then be added to this uh traders
as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication and with that we have come
to the end of this video on networking
interview questions and answers
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video
please ask away in the comments section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here